The Joe Rogan experience.
You've done an amazing job in this book of trying to boil it down for dummies
like me. But it's hard. It is.
It is a complicated and insanely nuanced subject. Yes,
and it's one of those things where it's like this many worlds theory.
For one example, the, the, the,
just the possibility that there's like, explain that.
Explain for people that don't understand what quantum mechanics even means.
Give them just like a little bit of that and then explain many worlds theory.
Yeah, a good, this is what I'm here to do. So, you know,
an electron take an electron,
quantum mechanics should apply to the entire universe,
but it becomes unmistakable when you look at little tiny things, right?
So we always are talking about electrons or atoms and so forth.
And electron has a position and, well, sorry, let me not even say that,
that even that was wrong.
It's just so hard to correctly talk about quantum mechanics, right?
If you were Isaac Newton before there was quantum mechanics,
there was classical mechanics and basically quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics are the only two big frameworks that have ever existed in physics.
You know,
classical mechanics was so good that everyone thought that was just right and
it's all better at filling the details until quantum mechanics came along and
changed things in classical mechanics and electron is a point.
It has a position, a location in space and has a velocity.
It's moving somewhere and from that you can predict what's going to happen.
Okay? Quantum mechanics says, no, no, no.
The electron has a wave function, so there's a wave. You know,
sometimes you hear this debate about are are things like electrons and photons,
particles or waves. The answer is that they are waves
and the wave function has this weird property that when you're not looking at
it, it's a wave. It's all spread out or it's localized somewhere,
but it obeys an equation. The Schrodinger equation. So far so good.
Just like regular physics, there's a thing, the wave function,
it obeys an equation. The Schrodinger equation.
You can predict what's going to happen next.
But the weird thing about quantum mechanics is that there's a whole separate set
of rules for what happens when you look at the thing. When you observe it,
when you measure it,
that's where things get squirreled with people describing it. Yes.
And that's where they want to go. Woo. On you. It's an opening to be woo. Right?
When you say like,
what do you mean observe something like does it have to be a conscious being?
Can it be a video camera? You know, that's just right here, right?
Is it the act of measuring the changes things? Well,
this is the puzzle. Okay.
This is what is called the measurement problem of quantum mechanics that the
rules we teach our students at Cal tech or anywhere else when we teach them
quantum mechanics in their sophomore year of college, uh,
the rules say when a system is observed,
when it is measured, it's state.
It's wave function changes dramatically suddenly and unpredictably.
Now, let me ask you this. How do we know this based on if,
if you're measuring it and it changes, how do we know?
Because we didn't measure it before. Like what,
what observations are we making that we understand the state of it before it's
measured without measuring it?
Good. There's a couple of ways. So, um, let, let,
let me make things even simpler.
Forget about where the electron is located and think about the electron is
spinning, right? Electron is spinning. Just like the earth spins.
It's really exactly like that. It's like a little spinning top,
except when you measure the spin,
you can sort of send the electron through a magnetic field and it will get
deflect either up or down, depending on whether it's spinning,
spin up or spin down. You only ever get one of two answers.
It's either going up or going down. It's nowhere in between.
This is an empirical measured fact. Okay. Um,
so that's a part of quantum mechanics.
That's the quantum fact that there's discrete set of possible answers to this
question is it's been in clockwise or counterclockwise, yes or no.
It's just those two possibilities. Nowhere in between. So if you're,
if you have a magnetic field that is oriented vertically,
send your electron through it. It gets deflected up. You say, Oh, it's spin up.
So now I've measured it spin. Now I know what its state is.
If I send it through another magnetic field or oriented vertically,
it will always be deflected up every single time we know what it is we're going
to measure it. Measuring it in this case doesn't change it.
It's in exactly that state. We know it. Okay,
now let's send it through a magnetic field that is oriented horizontally.
So it's going to be deflected either right or left.
We know exactly what state it's in, it's spinning this way,
but when you send it through that magnetic field that's oriented horizontally,
it gets deflected, left or right, 50 50 unpredictably.
There's no way we can predict it. And then once it is, so okay,
now it's been spinning up. You measured it, spinned, left.
Let's say send it through another magnet that is going vertically and now it's
50 50 again, it could be spin up or spin down. So somehow,
even though we knew exactly what state it was in,
we couldn't predict what would happen next. That is part of quantum mechanics.
So
the act of sending it through these things where it makes it vertical or
horizontal
and what is, what is happening to it when it's going through these things.
So in quantum mechanics,
what we say is that it's not that we don't know whether the electron is spinning
clockwise or counterclockwise. Um, it can be in a superposition of both.
That's just the spin version of the position of the electron can be spread out
in a, in a wave, right? It's,
it's truly not just that we are lacking some knowledge is that the knowledge
really isn't there. And again,
this is how we teach quantum mechanics in textbooks.
And then I'm going to correct it cause many worlds is much better.
But this is the standard textbook version. There's a wave function.
The wave function for a spin is it's either up or down or some combination.
And then there's a rule that says when you measure the spin,
you only get up or down. You don't see the wave function,
just like the cloud that you have for the electrons position.
When you look at it, you see it at a location.
So another way to get to make the same argument is take a little piece of,
I haven't a nice little image of this when I give talks,
little piece of uranium. So it's a radioactive,
a little chunk of metal and you put it in a bubble chamber.
So it is admitting radioactive particles and you detect the particles.
You can see a little streak of uh,
of motion when the particle leaves the uranium. Okay. Well, like I said,
when you're not looking at it, this electron is supposed to obey an equation,
the Schrodinger equation. And you can ask what the prediction is. When,
when a radioactive nucleus decays and gives off an electron,
what is its wave function going to do?
What is the wave functioning electron going to be?
And the answer is it goes off in a spherical wave.
It goes off in all directions at once evenly. Yeah, all directions evenly.
But you never see that. Is that [inaudible]
the shape of the piece of uranium? Does it vary?
No, because the electron gets from one individual nucleus of an atom.
Right? So the, the what the, the uranium is doing doesn't matter.
It's just like one Adam matters.
And the easiest thing for the electron to do is just to go out in a sphere.
It doesn't have to, we can go out and higher energy States. But the point is,
it's not going out in a straight line, but when you look at it,
you see a straight line, right?
That's the fundamental mystery of quantum mechanics.
That how we described the thing when we're not looking at it is different than
what we see when we look at it.
So when you're in pursuit of an understanding,
a deeper understanding of quantum mechanics, what you,
when you,
you're thinking about people from the 19 hundreds that are just sort of
basically getting the first steps going to understand this stuff.
When,
when you're talking about this lack of funding and the lack of encouragement for
people to pursue quantum mechanics,
you strongly feel like there are answers to these questions. Yeah,
that's right. That we just need better tools and a better understanding,
better equations. More time.
Yeah, me and Einstein think that's right.
So Einstein is one of the secret heroes of the book because he has this
reputation as someone who just couldn't quite accept quantum mechanics.
The title is something deeply hidden is a quote from Einstein. Uh,
when he was talking about when he was a kid and he had a compass, right?
And he was given his first magnetic compass and he could rotate it this way and
that way. And it always pointed North and you and I would go, huh, that's cool.
But he was Einstein. He's like, wow, this is amazing. Why?
How does it know where North is? Right? And he said,
there must be something deeply hidden that explains why it's doing this
mysterious thing. And he felt the same way about quantum mechanics that we have.
We gave these set of rules or called the Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics. One set of rules for when you're looking at it,
one set of rules for when you're not. And Einstein was like, Oh, come on.
Clearly this is not the final answer to the nature of reality, right?
He wanted you to know God's thoughts. He's like, I want to know everything.
We're not done yet. There must be more going on.
And so many worlds is one of proposed answers to what could be going on.
It's not the only one. There's alternatives,
but it's definitely my favorite is definitely the easiest one to, uh,
to write down. Let's put it that way. Okay,
so hit us with this many worlds theory. Okay?
So think about this electron you're going to you,
you say that it could be either spin up or spin down.
It's a combination of both. That's its wave function. You measure it.
You only ever see spin up or spin down.
So Copenhagen says that's because the wave function suddenly changed,
snapped into place when you observed it.
Don't ask me what it means to observe something that's not what Copenhagen lets
you ask many world says what you're missing is two things.
Number one, your a quantum system.
You are obeying the rules of quantum mechanics.
You're made of atoms and electrons and so forth. You have a wave function too.
Okay?
So you're secretly treating yourself as a classical thing when you make that
measurement. But you really should be treating yourself quantum mechanically.
Right? That's one thing. And the other thing is, uh,
something that Einstein invented, namely called entanglement.
When quantum mechanics says there's a wave function for a system,
it doesn't say there's a separate wave function for every particle, right?
It says that there's only one way function for the whole universe.
So the way I like to say it is imagine two particles come in and bounce off of
each other. Either one has a wave function and it's, you know, unpredictable.
Exactly what angle it's going to go off at. So both of those,
both of the particles that go off, you don't know where they're going,
but because momentum is conserved, if they came in at equal velocities,
they'll go out at equal velocities in opposite directions. If you measure one,
then you know where the other one is going, right? That's entanglement.
The observed state of one system can be related to the observed state of another
system. So those are the two ingredients.
Your quantum system and quantum systems can be entangled with each other.
So whoever it,
who was a graduate student when he invented this idea in the 1950s said, look,
when you measure that electron, what happens physically? Look,
forget about you're a person, you're conscious, all of that BS.
Like you're a physical system. You obey the Schrodinger equation. You,
you are quantum mechanical system. You obey the laws of physics.
So you look at the electron, your wave function changes.
It used to be you're just a person doing whatever you do.
But then after you look at the electron,
you become entangled with it and it splits.
So there is one part of the wave function that says the electron was spinning
clockwise and you measured it spinning clockwise.
And there's another part of the wave function that says the electron was
spinning counterclockwise and you saw it spinning counterclockwise.
Now everybody knows this like that that far. It's not controversial at all.
That's clearly the prediction of the equations of quantum mechanics.
But everyone else said, well that means that I'm some weird combination of,
I saw it spinning one way and I saw it spinning the other way.
But I've never felt that way. When I look at real electrons,
I see them one way or the other. That can't be, that can't be the final answer.
The wave function must somehow collapse and Everett said no.
What you're missing is there's now two separate worlds.
Both of those part of the wave function are real, but they're different worlds.
They will never interact with each other again.
What happens in one part of the way you function will not affect what happens in
the other part.
So now there's a version of you that's all the electrons spinning clockwise and
there's another version of you that's all.
It's spinning counterclockwise and that's just taking seriously the prediction
of quantum mechanics. It's not adding any extra stuff, any extra worlds,
anything like that.
That is the part where my brain broke the,
the idea that there's a you that observes it going clockwise and the you that
observes it going in a different direction like that is so hard to understand
you. Do you apply this in your regular life? Like, do you think,
like when you go home and you say hi to your wife and you open up the
frigerator,
do you think of yourself as this quantum being that's existing in this super
state?
So, I mean, there's a couple of answers to that. One is, you know, sure.
If I think about it like I really do believe it. You know,
I have a chapter in the book, which my editor resisted at at first,
but then he let me get away with it,
which is a dialogue between a young philosopher and her father who was a
physicist and the father is skeptical about all of this philosophical nonsense.
And she tries to explain how many worlds works to him. And at the end, you know,
his last question is, you know, do you really believe this?
I you really taking this seriously? And look, that's a perfectly attic.
Good question.
It's a very respectable question because it is many worlds.
It's not crazy or weird or bizarre, but it's certainly very,
very far away from our everyday experience. Right?
So what it's asking you to do is to say, I have these equations.
They are really,
really good at fitting what I do observe in the world and making predictions.
You know, I can build the large Hadron Collider, et cetera. Um,
I will take them seriously even for things that I can't directly observe cause
they're the best equations I have. Right.
Until a better set of equations come along, I will believe these equations.
And the implication of that is yeah, there's a whole bunch of worlds,
like a huge number, like a real, you know,
Jai humongously unimaginably big number may be an infinite number, maybe finite,
we don't know of different copies of you and they're being created all the time.
Uh, the good news is that it doesn't really affect how you go through life.
It doesn't really, um,
imply that you should behave any differently than you would if you just lived in
one world. But do you think of each choice that you make
possibly changing everything about the world that you exist in?
How are you, how are you looking at it, if you know what I'm saying?
Because you are a guy who probably understands it as good as anybody that's
alive. So as weird as this stuff sounds too, to me it sounds like an,
I mean it's almost impossible for me to comprehend. So I'm trying
to filter it through your understanding of it. Well,
I think that take his jacket off. We're going to see,
I know it's getting hot in here. Physics is heating us up. Um,
yeah, I'm not, I'm not exactly sure how to say it the best, you know. Um,
it doesn't, it, it doesn't change who you are.
It's certainly not true that you making a decision is what branches the wave
function of the universe. I guess that's the right thing to say.
Cause I want to stop all woo. Yeah. You can't hear that happen. Everyone,
you know, believe me,
the joke about how certain political choices imply that we're living in the
wrong branch of the wave function has been made many, many times. Right. But,
uh, you, it's not that your choices create different universes,
different universes get created and maybe you're different in them by a little
bit. In fact, I, you know,
I like to point out there is an app you can download if you have an iPhone
called universe splitter, which will, uh,
branch the wave function of the universe for you.
And then if you agree ahead of time to do one thing in one branch and another
thing and another branch,
then there will be multiple copies of you who are living different lives and
then you can deal with that and your therapist however you like.
But does the application exactly doing what it's doing is a basically a version
of measuring the spin of it's called universe splitter universe splitters only
for iPhones. Oh, my grandma's right now. Sorry. Freud people. Yeah, sorry.
It's not even a webpage is only a only an app. There's equivalent webpages,
but okay. I'm pulling it up right now. Yeah. And what so would you can do,
basically it sends a signal to a lab that coincidentally is located in Geneva,
Switzerland, but has nothing to do with the Higgs boson or anything like that.
Um, they send a single photon down a pipe to what's called a beam splitter.
So the wave function to the photon goes 50, 50, it gets sent left, it gets sent.
Right.
And if you agree and so then it sends back whether you ended up in the branch or
the wave function where it went left or where it went. There you go. One 99.
Come on. Yeah. That's the power of changing the universe is in your hands.
I downloaded it. I paid for it. I got it right here. Yeah.
So if you have any tough choices, uh, you can type in like, you know,
I want to have pizza or I want to have Chinese food for dinner tonight. Well,
it says in one universe, I will take a chance in the other one,
I will play this. Yeah, but you can, uh, you can correct those.
You can fill in whatever you want. Rowing. Yeah, that's the good part.
But what is, what is homecoming? I will ask her to marry me.
I will not ask her to marry me. I will accept this job.
I will go somewhere else. The equivalent of a quantum fortune cookie. Yeah.
But except that all possible fortunes have seen in different universes.
The bad news is you can't ever find out how things went in the other university.
You can't talk to the different universities. The problem, right,
it's the problem will be paralyzed by analysis. That's why it's,
you should act the same as if you just lived in one universe cause you can never
talk to the people in the other ones.
But now let's hit hit the brakes on the Wu gap. Yeah.
Cause people would like to believe that there are,
I mean are there an infinite number
of use existing
at the exact same time making various choices which send you off in a different
directions.
So number one, we don't know if it's infinite number or just really big,
but there's certainly a really, really big number that's big enough to be,
you know, big enough for whatever you want. But it's not everything. It's not,
the theory does not say everything happens somewhere. Right?
The theory says the Schrodinger equation is obeyed.
There's an equation that is obeyed.
So electrons will never convert into protons because electrons are negatively
charged and protons are positively charged.
And nowhere in this reneger equation can you violate the conservation of charge,
right? So there's plenty of things that don't happen,
but then there are plenty of things that do happen and some things are more
likely than others for you to experience. So again, it's, it's sort of a,
you know, it's a mind bendy thing,
but it's a straight forward prediction of the equations and it doesn't affect
our lives. It, there's no rule that says, you know, to be a moral person,
to be a good utilitarian and make the world happy, knowing that the world,
the way function is branching into multiple copies,
I should act differently somehow. It's,
it's exactly the same as it would be in the ordinary world.
So you and you are the ordinary world no matter how copies,
how many copies of you there are or how many versions of you, there's nothing.
So when all these copies are being made,
there's no essence of you that is traveling through one of the copies, right?
Like all of these people are separate people. So I use the analogy,
it's like identical twins.
They were the same zygote or whatever and now they're different people. Okay.
So that's the same thing like your you now and if you hit the button and branch
the wave function, there'll be two different people,
both of whom used to be you but not the same person anymore because different
things happen to them.
Now when people think about the concept of quantum mechanics and the way you're
talking about describing things in the micro and the macro,
you think of your existence itself very similar in a very similar manner.
The way you think of electrons,
the way you think of things being quantum is that you are a combination of all
these quantum things. Yeah.
So you don't operate in some sort of static state that's very like here and now
and and, and carbon and you can put it on a scale and it will never change.
There's constant versions of you.
Yeah.
It's kind of like a wishing where you know more and more versions of you are
being created all the time. And it's a,
it's an interesting thing because even the best trained physicists sort of think
intuitively, classically like, look, here's the [inaudible]
table. There's a bottle, right? You have to, yeah. To the breaks.
And this is how we evolve, right? That's how our brains work.
And like I said, you know,
many worlds is one respectable version of quantum mechanics.
There are other respectable versions,
more respectable than the textbook presentation, but they all,
all the other ones somehow lean on our classical experience.
And the textbook version certainly does, it says like,
you're a classical person observing a quantum mechanical system and so forth.
And Everett, when he was a graduate student, you know, he was,
he had arguments across the ocean with people in Copenhagen, you know,
who tried to push their way forward. And he's like, well,
why do you get to be classical? And the electron has to be quantum.
Like why aren't you quantum? Like why isn't everything,
what's so special about you? Really?
And he was trying to think of the quantum mechanics of the whole universe.
Right? We're using not a separate observer outside because he's doing the whole
universe all at once. And so everything had to be quantum.
And I think that that's another thing that is pushing us to appreciate the
foundations of quantum mechanics a little bit more,
is that we're trying to understand quantum gravity.
We're trying to understand quantum cosmology,
the universe all at once obeying the rules of quantum mechanics.
And the conventional Copenhagen theory is just not up to it.
[inaudible].